Linda is in Pennsylvania
hi Linda how are you hi Dave thanks so
much for taking my call
sure what's up well I'm calling with a
question about a huge mistake that I
made a long time ago before I found out
about your program I found out about
your program in March and started in
April and I got my husband on board and
in the meantime we paid off about twenty
seven thousand dollars in debt where two
girls like a problem thanks but the
problem that we have is I the mistake is
I co-signed for a student loan for my
son my son is 23 years old he still
hasn't graduated college we're now
basically estranged from him we're not
speaking to him why just because of his
very irresponsible abusive to us
emotionally and verbally my husband is a
stepfather so it's pretty much been me
that's been raising so the mistake is
now that he's not paying his student
loans and we're paying thirty so a
cosigner does room right yes he went to
Penn State University for engineering is
12 credits to go so he didn't even
graduate and anytime we would ask him
what his plan is basically that caused
them to not speak to us and now we have
a lot of sentiment on because we're
stuck paying these bills so my question
is we're basically debt free except for
our home and we're now in the mode to
fully fund our emergency fund oh you got
ourselves not alone well and that's I
guess my question to you is what to do
is a high interest rate loan like not
percent my husband is just so resentful
because you know because of the whole
situation and he just wants us to attack
came off the mortgage hoping that he'll
come around
and then hopefully you know do what he's
supposed to do do the right
and payoffs alone so I guess that's
where he's on board I didn't hear
anything here that tells me there's any
probability of that happening right so
and then my other question is I've
looked into refinancing but as long as
my song-song alone the weight is
particularly high because he has
terrible credit refinance them listen
listen you're gonna end up paying this
I'm sorry because you have a 23 year old
who's being a twerp
he's probably abusive he's not worth
spit right now he ain't even finished
his dadgum engineering degree and he's
mad he's mad at the world and he's king
of the world and it's gonna be a decade
for he grows up your speed and pay them
you're gonna pay it because you're
totally wait and simply fully fund our
emergency fund it would take about five
or six months you you have a hundred and
thirty thousand dollar student loans
need to pay what's your and what is your
household income five hundred and
seventy thousand so you're gonna pay it
off in a couple years
yeah three years it worth now - you
think yeah sixty thousand out of 170
says you're living on 110 when you can
do that Tom yeah and listen I don't
blame you for having your heart broken I
really don't blame your husband because
his stepsons a twerp for being mad about
that but you signed this and he married
you and this is you're not getting out
of this and the kid ain't gonna pay it
so you're gonna have to I'm so sorry
sorry for the heartbreak and the
estrangement but I would just take it on
and get her done in two years